family that was terrible I know that you
can make searing this week you're gonna
be the perfect home makeups people talk
about what an ideal time the mid-century
was for families this week we're gonna
give it a try and see if we can live up
to that mid-century domestic ideal we
have this handy chart that tells us what
the perfect wife is and we get to create
ourselves how exciting yeah um one is
gonna be negative
[Music]
what's her cold feet on her husband at
night for a husband should be there to
warm you up
that's what I say so negative one for me
religious sends children to church or
Sunday school and goes herself well I
could have had 10 points for this one
that's luck has meals on time
I can cook about two dinners and carry
on an interesting conversation I mean I
think I'm [ __ ] fascinating so yeah
good sense of humor jolly and gay caputo
can play a musical instrument your wife
is just there to entertain you with her
interesting conversation and her violin
play with dresses for breakfast I don't
eat breakfast and I don't dress so oh
man it's not looking good I'm very poor
parentheses failure I'm a failure as a
wife and a mother apparently as
suspected I am a total failure
that doesn't sound great but I heard
that it's higher than Oh G
when I look at this my initial reaction
was discussed I would think that at the
time that my grandmother was this
American housewife she wanted to do
these things it just makes me angry to
think that somebody could have looked at
her and been checking off boxes she
handled her house and her life and her
children with grace I will be channeling
her and I
also want to pay a little homage to her
and like all aboard she did and see if I
can do too right after having my son I
got to have a year maternity leave so I
got used to what it's like to be a
stay-at-home mom and I really loved it
so decided to quit my job and not go
back to work you're always thinking
about am i doing it right I'm just
nervous about these rules about what my
role is supposed to be hopefully it
won't make me unhappy with my choices my
family dynamic has been heavily shaped
by my postpartum depression and OCD so
my husband has been running our
household as the primary caretaker for
going on seven years now I have to live
up to what he is already so efficient at
and what he already does so well it's
kind of scary to ask him to step aside
and let me take the reins of something
that I have quite honestly failed at in
the past
oh you guys are stressed out about this
as I am I'm so stressed up okay I'm just
nervous my husband's gonna get used to
it I'm supposed to dress myself before I
do anything house I don't want to do it
Maryna gram of apron now I'm really hot
in this thing maybe it's oppression I've
been planning what I'm gonna do this
week here it is church every day that's
the big points I don't think rose going
to church counts
she walked in and then James got bored
and then she left that doesn't count
this morning I decided to get up and go
balls to the wall put together and care
for my family at the same time hey guys
what are you doing I'm supposed to make
you breakfast
waiting for you for a while how can I
get ready and be presentable just to be
presentable
check out my outfit I think it's okay
for what I'm trying to accomplish the
fleek
I felt I still have car lures in my
husband's gone to work and now my mom's
here feeding my daughter breakfast
outsourcing the clean house thank you
mommy
I went to get a glass for coffee that's
God that's clean tuition
okay the dishwasher in the hallways it
was heartbreaking because it was a
reminder of how little faith he has in
me as a homemaker and how truly earned
that lack of faith has been I can do him
today this is so much of her this is not
easy
this is stressed out right now I had a
last-minute meeting I have no food I
have nothing prepared it said I had to
have meals delivered on time it didn't
say that they had to be homemade if
those ladies had posts mates they'd be
using it some more I tried to check each
box off on the guy it was just one
failure after another after another so I
was gonna clean the kitchen but I made
these amazing pancakes and Delilah asked
me to sit with her while she ate them
and you know what that's a lot more fun
what do you remember breakfast him I was
coming up here what was gonna Thea's the
one thing I know how to make I think I
would love to keep cooking going forward
I was really surprised that I actually
enjoyed cooking this week dinner is Sir
there was a really great satisfaction in
it it was mainly the gratitude on my
family's face I'm really happy that I
feel like doing it more for my own
reasons for my family but going forward
I'm not going to be cooking because
that's what the wife Chart told me to do
this scale has been haunting me this
whole week it's been on my fridge and I
generated and I didn't goodbye
patriarchy I still so no buttons and
daren't no socks darn it I did not
accomplish the stuff again meet
housekeeper has the meals on time no I
did not do that one no meals were on day
I know they made dresses nice for
breakfast but I don't care I had a
clothes on I think I took better wait
what
wow that's crazy I must eat it I'm
average he's got so excited I raised up
on this horrible scale then I realized
like I don't care there's no such thing
as a perfect homemaker
nor should there be the only perfect is
the best that you can be for yourself
and for your family just made me really
happy to be in such an equal partnership
with my husband when I looked at this
sheet I was angry and I thought women
shouldn't have to do this this is
[ __ ] but as I went through the week
I realized that my own husband was doing
all of these things and that's not right
either after this week I'm committed to
creating an equal partnership in the
home being a stay-at-home mom has been
my choice back then women didn't have a
choice maybe grandma had this a Dilek
life because that was the only option
for her once it started getting into the
70s she went back to school and got a
degree who knows what she would have
accomplished with her life if those
opportunities had been there for her
when she was younger no one should have
to devote their entire life to their
family because it is expected of them to
me this is such a special role but in
the future I hope that people can enjoy
it and not feel so many external
pressures I don't think a woman can have
it all having it all is trying to do
everything that society tells you you
should have I believe that a woman can
have everything that she wants so what's
really important is knowing what you
want for yourself and for your family